dans ce contexte d'opérations spéciales
aucune frappe n'est dirigée vers des
civils tués hier en ukraine invasion
russe ces mots n'ont jamais existé dans
les médias d'état et ils sont en train
de disparaître des rares dernier média
indépendant en russie depuis le début du
conflit lagence régulatrice des médias
en russie rose comme nador vérifie
scrupuleusement les contenus publiés
toute mention négatif des opérations
russes doit être supprimé et ceux qui ne
se plierait pas aux exigences du pouvoir
s'expose à une fermeture définitive
ce mercredi la justice a demandé le
blocage de deux médias indépendants la
webtv deutsch et la radio echo de moscou
qui aurait diffusé de fausses
informations sur l'action de l'armée
russe le journal novaïa gazeta et a
échappé de peu
et voilà ce matin novaïa gazeta ne parle
plus de guerre mais d'opérations
spéciales en ukraine c'était ça ou la
fermeture à terme du journal indépendant
dans le conflit les troupes russes sont
aussi présentés comme libératrice d'une
menace qui viendrait du gouvernement
ukrainien sur ces images issues du
journal télévisé de la première chaîne
de télévision russe les téléspectateurs
assistaient une opération militaire
spéciale planifié selon eux pour
protéger le dombass
ici c'est l'hystérie des médias
ukrainiens qui provoque la fuite des
habitants de kiev s'étaient opposés à
chaignay pouvoir en france la chaîne
arte et le média spoutnik n'échappe pas
à la règle comme en témoigne cet article
où l'on évoque la reddition de soldats
ukrainien des soldats bien traités selon
le journaliste photos à l'appui
contrairement aux soldats russes
victimes des ukrainiens traité ici de
nazis
les deux médias viennent de voir leur
diffusion interdite dans toute l'union
européenne
ce qui souligne leur désinformation
toxiques et nuisible